there was a time when bill burr couldn't
sell tickets every comic has a come up
and i just talked to nate barghetti
about his experience seeing bill burrs
and i just watched bill burr a lot i
watched for
i mean
obsessively i've you know i would watch
him at all the clubs i'd watch him i
remember going to caroline's and
he's not even have the rooms not even
sold out at caroline's i remember his
opinion anthony the famous philadelphia
incident i remember when it happened he
came back and was telling us about it
before it kind of blew up on youtube wow
uh we were
like guys the show was crazy like never
forget that comedy is a marathon for
everyone in fact